hola hola
muy buenas noches como esta
pues yo muy contento de estar aquí con
ustedes el día de hoy muy contento de la
invitación que me hicieron aquí dt de ex
colonia del bosque aquí a villahermosa
tabasco
y el día de hoy quiero hablarles un tema
que a mí me apasiona muchísimo un
poquito de lo que estamos haciendo en el
congreso de nuevo león sí pero viene
tenemos que ayudar a una lucha que hemos
estado impulsando desde hace muchos años
mucho antes e incluso desde que entramos
en la política yo el día de hoy
les quiero presentar a maría emilia
no la vemos
[Aplausos]
maría emilia está cursando preescolar es
una niña
muy muy risueña un poco tímida al
principio pero después muy vivaracha muy
amiguera
le encantan las princesas le gusta mucho
pintar y a sus 4 años de edad representa
la viva imagen de la niñez y de la
inocencia
tiene como nos gusta decir toda la vida
por delante
tiene un potencial infinito puede hacer
y decidir hacer con su vida lo que ella
quiera o al menos así me gusta
imaginarlo
hace unos días yo le pregunté a mi hija
hoy en emilia
qué quieres ser cuando seas grande
es una de las preguntas más profundas
que le puedes hacer una persona de
cuatro años
se los juro que ni se inmutó ni lo pensó
dos veces me miró fijamente y me dijo
sirena
y me encantó me encantó me derritió pero
lo pensó un poquito mejor y me dijo no
sabes que no papá
fíjate que yo puedo ser sirena cuando yo
quiera
de hecho puedo ser sirena ahora misma
mejor quiero ser doctora
oye mi hijita qué bien me encanta a
veces eso es una muy bonita decisión oye
que quieras estudiar para poder ayudar a
la gente a tener salud eso es algo muy
bonito es una profesión muy noble no me
oye felicidades y la verdad es que me
pudo haber dicho yo asumí que dijo
doctor en medicina ya tampoco le quise
preguntar si doctora de sirenas o
doctora de personas pero
bien pudo haberse referido a doctores
matemáticas o doctora en química doctor
en derecho o empresaria activista
presidenta de la república porque no
en 1907 finlandia y su historia por
primera vez
en sus elecciones generales las mujeres
pudieron votar y en esa misma elección
las mujeres pudieron contender para
cargos de elección popular y ocuparon
por primera vez asientos en el
parlamento hoy más de 110 años después
finlandia tiene un gobierno conformado
por una coalición de cinco partidos
políticos
cuatro de ellos perdón los cinco
liderados por mujeres cuatro de ellas
menores de 35 años hoy a sus 34 años de
edad
sana marín es la primer ministra más
joven del mundo
en latinoamérica y en méxico ciertamente
también hemos hemos dado pasos
importantes para alcanzar la igualdad
entre mujeres y hombres sin embargo hay
hay algo hay algo que todavía no nos
permite salir adelante como quisiéramos
algo que hace que sigamos arrastrando
viejos prejuicios que es que no sabemos
por qué los seguimos cargando con ellos
y a pesar de que vemos cada vez más
oportunidades políticas académicas y
empresariales para las mujeres seguimos
sin salir adelante seguimos sin poder
romper ese estúpido techo de cristal que
amenaza el talento de tantas mujeres en
méjico
y es que no nos explicamos porque si
desde la escuela les enseñamos a
nuestras hijas y a nuestros hijos que
hombres y mujeres somos iguales e
incluso vemos que en el desempeño
escolar las mujeres tienden a apuntar un
poco más arriba que los hombres y si nos
vamos a las estadísticas y vemos qué
hay mucho más mujeres haciendo
postgrados que hombres
si esto es netamente de un tema de
desempeño y de capacidad deberíamos
entonces también de estar viendo mínimo
un 50 por ciento de mujeres en altos
puestos directivos en las empresas
mexicanas y no es así y eso que nos
sentimos si nos asumimos ya muy lejos de
aquellos tiempos en donde a la mujer se
le discrimina va al grado de no poder
poseer ningún bien o propiedad de no
poder heredar de no poder votar
mucho menos contender por un cargo
después de elección popular no podía
pagar impuestos bueno yo creo que esta
última quizás no les moleste tanto que
siga vigente pero
y pensamos que todo eso ya está muy
lejano y sin embargo no nos damos cuenta
que al día de hoy existen mujeres en
méjico que su régimen de seguridad
social no les permite inscribir a sus
maridos
en el seguro social como sus colegas
varones y pueden hacerlo mujeres que son
discriminadas y hasta despedidas por
querer tener familia y embarazarse o
mujeres que sufren de una violencia por
una doble jornada laboral es decir
después de salir de sus casas a trabajar
para procurar el sustento económico para
sus familias llegan a su casa y se les
exige que hagan las labores domésticas y
se encarguen de la crianza de los hijos
porque se espera de ellas por ser
mujeres normalizando así una
subordinación de la mujer en nuestra
sociedad lo cual es absurdo
tenemos aquí y nos estamos enfrentando
pues a dos problemas uno social y otro
legal socialmente hablando venimos de
como especie seguimos evolucionando ya
desde hace muchos años de una
construcción primigenia que se basa en
la ley del más fuerte en la
supervivencia del más apto y de manera
biológica entendemos porque quizás somos
un poco así pero también hemos visto
como como sociedad como como humanidad
hemos ido evolucionando hemos ido
cambiando y al día de hoy gracias a
nuestro crecimiento ya nuestra madurez
hemos reconocido la importancia y el
valor
de reconocerle a la mujer un papel de
igual como individuo de nuestra sociedad
sin embargo
y como bien lo explica carol en criado
en su libro invisible existe una cosa
que se llama el gen der sar
gat la brecha informática de género es
decir que durante siglos nuestros
sistemas de gobierno y nuestros sistemas
de ciencias fueron concebidos por
hombres que usaron criterios masculinos
a poder diseñar muchas de las cosas que
hoy rigen nuestros sistemas sociales
cosas a veces tan imperceptibles pero
que si dejan huella como por ejemplo la
altura de los anaqueles de los
supermercados
o la ingeniería de un automóvil
los estudios clínicos farmacéuticos o
los estudios científicos todos centrados
siempre en un predeterminado masculino
porque porque a través de los años
fueron hombres los que diseñaron un
sistema y no tomaron en cuenta porque no
pudieron no quisieron o simplemente no
pensaron
y tomar en cuenta el punto de vista el
criterio femenino
y así es como tenemos una sociedad
incompleta porque porque todas estas
estos prejuicios hacia la mujer que se
tienen en muchas de estas ciencias se
tienen también en ciencias como las
ciencias jurídicas y las ciencias
gubernamentales que rigen muchas de las
naciones contemporáneas hoy en día
méxico no siendo la excepción
entonces aquí tenemos el segundo
problema
si la sociedad te discrimina
la ley que fue creada por individuos de
esa sociedad
también te discriminan
pero hemos visto y aquí ya lo hemos
visto y vimos este ejemplo y vemos
ejemplos en méxico y en otras partes del
mundo se oye donando pero es que es que
la sociedad ya no es así ya hemos
evolucionado ya ya cada vez tenemos más
oportunidades académicas más
oportunidades laborales y políticas y
sociales para que las mujeres puedan
prosperar en nuestra sociedad
bueno si eso es cierto porque porque la
sociedad es como un organismo vivo que a
través de los años y de las décadas va
madurando y aprendiendo va creciendo va
evolucionando
pero por lo mismo la ley
es un espejo de la sociedad debe de
cambiar madurar y evolucionar como si
fuera también un ser vivo junto con esa
sociedad y es por eso que todo
legislador
todo buen legislador
debe poner mucha atención a la gente que
representa y tomar en cuenta toda esta
evolución todos estos cambios
en todos estos procesos para entonces
incorporarlos y actualizarlos en la ley
y aquí mi hipótesis lo que mis mis
colegas y mi equipo de trabajo y un
servidor nos planteamos allá en nuevo
león
podría
podría la ley utilizarse para allanar el
camino
y podemos entonces apoyar así a que la
sociedad dé ese salto cuántico que
quisiéramos ver en la lucha por la
igualdad podemos a través de pequeños
cambios legislativos darle ese
empujoncito a la gente y alcanzar la
igualdad con la que soñamos nosotros
queremos que es así
porque es bueno
de nada nos sirve
de nada nos sirve decirles a nuestras
hijas que pueden ser doctoras si el día
de mañana que lleguen al hospital las
vamos a hacer sentir que ese no es su
lugar
ahí es donde me di cuenta
de que el empoderamiento de la mujer en
la lucha por la igualdad no es
suficiente por supuesto que es necesario
son muy necesarias todas las acciones
afirmativas que hemos hecho a través de
los años para lograr que los derechos de
la mujer sean parejos con los del hombre
pero es solamente la mitad de la
ecuación
para lograr la igualdad verdaderamente
el empoderamiento de la mujer no es
suficiente necesitamos reeducar al varón
necesitamos como varones replantearnos
nuestro rol en la sociedad en la familia
como colega como amigo como padre como
hijo como hermano como esposo
y tenemos que darnos cuenta de una vez
por todas que en esta lucha por la
igualdad
nuestra masculinidad no se disminuye en
lo mínimo
y ahí es donde yo me di cuenta
que no solamente se lo debo a mi hija
se lo debo a mi hijo también
le debo a él y le debo a ella una
educación igualitaria
para que aprendan con respeto y que el
respeto se le debe a todo ser humano por
el simple hecho de existir y que el
valor que se le asigna a una persona no
tiene nada que ver con su ideología con
su género con su raza con su religión
sino con el contenido
y así es como nos dimos a la tarea
de nuevo léon impulsar iniciativas en
materia de paridad y de igualdad de
género
de las cuales estamos orgullosos y
esperamos que esto se replique en todos
lados con la finalidad de poco a poco ir
impulsando ese cambio en el pensamiento
de la mayoría de la sociedad que no
exista discriminación para beneficiarios
de lista lyon el caso de nuevo león es
lo que les decía hace rato las mujeres
trabajadoras al servicio del estado de
nuevo léon no pueden inscribir a sus
maridos en su esquema de seguridad
social no pueden inscribir a sus
familias como sus colegas varones si
pueden hacerlo porque
porque esta distinción
el impulso de políticas públicas para
que pueda haber prácticas equitativas de
salarios porque 'si mujeres y hombres
hacemos trabajo del mismo valor no
ganamos entonces lo mismo
e incluir el concepto de violencia por
doble jornada en las leyes para proteger
a la mujer de este maltrato y poder
generar también conciencia de que en el
hogar necesitamos corresponsabilidad en
las labores domésticas y en la crianza
de los hijos así como el sustento
económico del hogar por igual
la responsabilidad compartida pues en
las tareas del hogar y el cuidado de los
hijos y algo de lo que me siento
sumamente orgulloso
hace muchos años incluso desde antes de
que yo pensara entrar a la arena
política se me hizo sumamente injusto
al momento de que nazca tu hijo
o tu hijo o que adoptes un hijo o una
hija los hombres no tengamos el mismo
derecho de tener una licencia de
paternidad para poder estar con ellos
para poder apoyar a nuestra pareja y
para poder es sobre todo vivir los
primeros días de nuestra familia de
nuestros niños y nuestras niñas en
nuestro hogar
entonces ahí te das cuenta que la ley
también te discrimina y te asigna un rol
exterior estereotipado en un gen en tu
género
también como hombre
la ampliación de la licencia por
nacimiento adopción de hijos para
promover una paternidad responsable es
necesario de esto me siento sumamente
orgulloso porque esto para los
trabajadores al servicio del estado de
nuevo léon ya es una realidad de los
cinco días que teníamos el año pasado
bueno que tenían
este año tienen 15 días el siguiente año
tendrá una semana más y así
sucesivamente hasta alcanzar las 8
semanas de estándar internacional
es la primera ley así en este país yo
espero que esto sea una realidad pronto
para todos los hombres trabajadores en
la república mexicana
estamos
en la antesala de un gran cambio
social y cultural de una transformación
de nuestro paradigma
en dónde
vemos que si se puede tenemos ejemplos
de que si se puede impulsar estos
cambios lo hemos visto en nuevo léon lo
queremos ver en todas en todos los
congresos del país lo queremos ver en el
congreso de la unión en donde mujeres y
hombres
podamos explotar y maximizar todo el
potencial que tenemos que ofrecerle este
país
en donde podamos de una vez por todas
asumir ese compromiso generacional que
tenemos
de alcanzar la igualdad entre mujeres y
hombres y de una vez por todas
deshacernos de todo piso pegajoso
deshacernos de todo techo de cristal
y poderle garantizar a nuestras hijas
que el día de mañana con toda certeza
nadie las va a frenar por el hecho de
ser mujeres y que pueden elegir y ser
exitosas siendo
doctoras ingenieras
físicas generales
pilotos de carrera
embajadores
senadoras
presidentes de la república
o bien porque no también
sirenas muchas gracias
te amo
gracias